a spy movie easy enough to make good you
have a good villain a good hero that
have the stakes high enough for you to
give a [ __ ] about simple right
really it's not the cold light of day
so the cold light of day stars Henry
Cavill and he's you know he's gonna be
the new Superman and his family ends up
disappearing and then he gets wrapped
into a spy movie I keep it vague like
that because that's really all you need
to know about the movie that's really
all you remember when you come out of
the movies this movie's been raked
through the coals I heard it was
terrible so I was like alright I'm gonna
give this movie a shot you know maybe
I'll be the guy who enjoys it a few
minutes of the movie I was like this is
what happens when a nine-year-old writes
a script in cran first of all you have
Henry Cavill he's the main good guy and
if he has acting prowess it really
doesn't show in this movie at all I
really blame the script I mean the
script is shoddy his character you don't
care about you do not give a [ __ ] if
this random normal everyday guy solves
this big spy case you don't give a [ __ ]
if he finds his family alive you're just
watching the movie thinking why am i
watching this movie in the script the
whole thing is he has to find this
briefcase a briefcase because you know
it's a spy movie and they really
couldn't think of anything so like I
don't know what did pulp fiction do this
new briefcase I know people have been
going after briefcases long before Pulp
Fiction did Pulp Fiction made it stylish
he almost did it like that because he
was like yeah you know briefcase it's a
classic you can tell in this movie they
were like oh yeah briefcase because
that's just what they do in spy movies
dude we gotta make it legit duh and upon
the terrible dialogue and the movie
that's just thrown together we're good
guys are good guys cuz they're good guys
and bad guys are bad guys because
they're bad guys and I really mean that
- you meet a villain they're like come
with me trust me
I'm a good guy you're like yeah don't
trust them why because they're bad guys
trying to act like good guys where's the
suspense where's the mystery where's the
curveball and they're terrible shots
with guns - there's one scene where one
of the bad guys was going after Henry
Cavill with an Uzi shooting at him and
missing as he was going up a staircase
five feet from them I'm not talking they
were shooting a 22 in a hurricane and
alright win factor of missed it was an
Uzi dude you can't you can't screw that
up not at that close range but anything
newsy things just like the least of the
scripts problems like that 17th thing
that's wrong with it but I had to point
it out and Bruce Willis is in this movie
for about 10 minutes
worth mentioning kind of because I think
Bruce Willis being in this movie for
about ten minutes of screen time is the
only reason that this movie didn't come
out on like a Netflix exclusive they're
like ah we're gonna film a movie for
Netflix Bruce Willis signed on [ __ ]
never got to pay for it to be theatrical
and damn it it doesn't have that kid
being Superman in it you know okay it
does alright well there's reason to then
they shoehorn this hot chick in the
movie because they need a hot chick in a
movie like this all right we got Henry
Cavill running around for no reason
whatsoever what else is missing oh let's
just have a hot chick in it thank you
hot chick for making this movie kind of
watchable not really watchable but look
a bowl I guess that's the term and then
when you've completely given up on this
movie more shit's happening at the end
more driving scenes and shaky cam
because that's the thing to do now I
swear to God I swear to you all eyes
owned out I didn't sleep or anything I
was watching the movie but it was like
when you read a book and you get like
three pages in you're like I can't
remember a thing I just read for the
past three pages I have to reread it it
was like that terrible acting terrible
premise terrible writing impossible
scenarios and there's a spy movie so
it's supposed to be you know like pseudo
possible you know like fringe possible
where you're like oh we need a spy movie
no this is just like the physics of it
or just [ __ ] however I'm kind of
excited folks I haven't given one of
these ratings in a while I almost forgot
how to do it let's warm up the cold
light of day is [ __ ] you're gonna
walk out of the movie going what was the
point of that [ __ ] my arms are folded as
I am reviewing this movie that's how
closed off I am terrible body language
are your favorite spy movie out there
what is it comment below let me know
whatever it is don't worry even if it's
a guilty pleasure it's better than this
and as always if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]